the Joe Rogan experience by the way when
I speak I'm speaking it's not it's not
my feelings and whether I'm right or
wrong seeing this is what the vid I'm a
yoga teacher so I teach what the Yogi's
teach the Nashes ganache is a being he's
a Jeeva Jeeva means he's a soul like in
India they say you don't have a soul you
are a soul you have a body so the body's
change but the soul is eternal so that's
called the Jeeva tattva you understand
that you're separate then your your we
are separate than our bodies we were
said like you said earlier we're
separate from our thoughts were separate
from our subtle body or mind so you take
on a different row ghen machine a raghu
raghunatha machine and sometimes the
machines are good at warfare fighting
sometime the machines are good art
sometimes the machines they're they're
just like a different vehicle you would
drive they different you got a Porsche
or you got a 18-wheeler they're both
good for different things so in the same
way we have some karma as we're karma
ties and you have some karma to have
this body that has such good fortune or
poor fortune or some great success and
it's the Karma of the body but you have
to leave that body so Ganesh is also a
post brahma is also a post you could
have been a Brahma in a previous life or
could be one in a previous life and you
get a body just like you get a body in
this life according to you how you act
and how you behave and how you think and
the people you associate with they give
you a body for example if you and I grow
up together and all we talk about is
martial arts we got pictures of Arnold
Schwarzenegger on our wall we start to
create a body that emulates those heroes
and if we couldn't care less and we just
like watching TV and do nothing we get a
body according to so in this lifetime
we're making bodies then we're making
our minds we're making our intelligence
but the Yogi's say that everything that
we do is a practice just like I just
found out today that you were Taekwondo
champion by reading your bio I know you
read my bio I read your bio on Wikipedia
I was like I gotta know more so I just
know you from just rolling around with
you and that type of camaraderie so you
got that way from a practice it didn't
just like spontaneously come you
practiced and you bring that practice
with you wherever you go and you can get
better at the practice or you can get a
little good little down the practice but
the Yogi's say that everything that we
do is a practice it's our thoughts our
intelligence our skills our spirituality
our addictions they don't just fall from
the sky we work on them and you'll hit
and that's why there's these things
which another thing I don't know if
you've ever done this on your show study
the lives of what are they called
savants or like these prodigies
unbelievable four years old musical
prodigies yeah like where is that coming
from the Yogi's say it's not random it's
not weird it's not quirky it's not
unexplainable it's a practice or that
was that child chess player from Norway
who could play like six people backwards
and meet them and not that he was not
facing them he's memorizing their board
where do you get that type of
intelligence the Yogi's say it's a
practice or Mozart and Chopin we're here
like virtuosos at four how and you'll
hear you'll see like the Saints of India
they'll be spiritual virtuosos like from
a very early age like my teachers
teachers teacher like a was a
grandfather teacher he was like a master
of Sanskrit at age four whoa and could
give class on it and could imagine that
at age four you don't say you know what
I was doing you know what I was doing at
age four I was wrecking [ __ ] I was
breaking things yeah lighting things on
fire
you know Shankar Acharya another great
like teacher of India age eight he
renounced the world had a initiated ten
thousand disciples changed the course of
all of India he at eight he wrote
commentaries he go to Columbia
University read commentaries on the gita
by this person who at age eight walked
away from his mother and said I'm
leaving for the forest
it's it's unbelievable this stuff's
unreal
[Applause]